PUSHED TO GO AHEAD AND HAVE
PEOPLE CELEBRATE OR  AT THEIR
DISCRETION, TOMORROW FOR EASTER
SUNDAY, CONGRESSMAN ERIC SWAL
WELL  JOINS US THE
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN,
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT,
CONGRESSMAN?
WELL WANT TO WORSHIP TOMORROW,
OF ANY FAITH AND DOING SO,
WHETHER IT BE A SYNAGOGUE,
WHETHER IT BE A CHURCH, AND THEY
WANT TO DO IT.
WHAT WOULD YOU ADVISE?
>> WELL FIRST, HAPPY EASTER, OR
PASSOVER, AND I’M SORRY THAT’S
NOT THE CASE.
I WISH I COULD BE AT CHURCH
TOMORROW CELEBRATING EASTER AS
WELL, BUT I’M GOING TO FOLLOW
THE GUIDELINES AND ACTUALLY, THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS A PERSON
CERTAINLY OF FAITH IS TELLING
CHURCH LEADERS TO OBSERVE THE
CDC GUIDELINES AND THE
SOONER WE ALL OBSERVE THEM
THE SOONER WE ALL CAN GET BACK
TO OUR HOUSES OF WORSHIP.
NEIL: CONGRESSMAN, HAVE YOU
GIVEN MUCH THOUGHT, I DO WANT TO
GET INTO THE STIMULUS BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT’S WHAT WE’RE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT BUT WHAT WOULD MAKE
YOU COMFORTABLE, UNWINDING SOME
OF THESE STAY-AT-HOME OR
SHELTER IN PLACE PROVISIONS?
WHAT WOULD YOU WANT TO LOOK FOR
IN CONSULTATION WITH OTHERS
IN YOUR STATE, THE GOVERNOR,
WHAT HAVE YOU, BECAUSE THERE ARE
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FACTORS, WHAT
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD SAY ALL
RIGHT, I COULD SEE LOOSENING UP
A BIT.
>> YEAH, I’VE GIVEN A LOT OF
THOUGHT TO THIS , NEIL BECAUSE I
WANT TO GET BACK TO REOPENING
AMERICA AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
SO I THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST,
COUNTY-BY-COUNTY, LOOKING AT THE
HOSPITALIZATION CASES, AS SOON
AS YOU START TO SEE A STEADY
DECLINE, WHERE ON WEDNESDAY YOU
HAD FEWER CASES THAN YOU DID ON
TUESDAY, AND SO ON, SECOND,
WIDER ACCESS TO DIAGNOSTIC
TESTING THAT CAN TELL US IF
PEOPLE HAVE ANTIBODIES SO THEY
ARE IMMUNE, I BELIEVE THAT AREAS
THAT LIKE THE BAY AREA, BY THE
WAY, IN ALAMEDA COUNTY MY
HOME COUNTY WE HAVE AROUND 700
CASES AND THAT IS REMARKABLY LOW
AND WE WERE THE FIRST TO SHELTER
IN PLACE SO WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SHELTER OUT OF PLACE VERY SOON
BUT THAT MAY MEAN HAVING TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS ON ANY INCOMING TO
THE BAY AREA, FROM PLACES WITH
HIGHER CASES WHERE THEY AREN’T
STARTING TO COME DOWN SO JUST AS
WE GO INTO A SHELTER IN PLACE
, I THINK WE CAN PHASE OUT
OR  MAYBE RESTAURANTS BEING OPEN
AT HALF CAPACITY, NON-ESSENTIAL
WORKERS GOING BACK TO WORK BUT
FOLLOWING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINES BUT WIDE ACCESS TO
TESTING NOT JUST KNOWING IF YOU
HAVE COVID BUT ALSO IF YOU HAD
IT IN THE PAST THAT WOULD MAKE
ME FEEL COMFORTABLE AND SOME
AREAS COME OUT OF IT FASTER AND
HAVE TO PROTECT AGAINST THE
AREAS THAT AREN’T OUT OF IT
YET.
NEIL: CONGRESSMAN THERE’S BEEN A
BIG BATTLE BETWEEN REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS OVER THIS
ADDITIONAL $250 BILLION IN
FINANCING THAT WOULD WORK TO
BEEF UP THE SMALL BUSINESS LOANS
, AND/OR  GRANTS, AND WE
HAD CHUCK GRASSLEY ON A LITTLE
EARLIER SAYING DEMOCRATS SHOULD
KNOW THERE’S GOING TO BE
FOLLOW-UP STIMULUS AND RELIEF,
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO DO IT
WITH THIS.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THAT?
>> WELL, I WANT MORE RELIEF TO
COME, WHETHER IT’S 250 BILLION
OR  MORE, I THINK WE’LL PROBABLY
NEED MORE, BUT WHAT WE’RE SAYING
RIGHT NOW IS GET THE MONEY OUT
THE DOOR THAT WE ALREADY VOTED
ON.
WE SPOKE WITH SECRETARY MNUCHIN
ON A HOUSE DEMOCRATIC CALL ON
WEDNESDAY, AND HE SAID OF THE
349 BILLION TO GO TO SMALL
BUSINESSES, ONLY 96 BILLION HAS
GONE OUT, AS OF WEDNESDAY SO
WE’RE ALL FOR CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE RELIEF BUT WE WANT TO
GET THE MONEY OUT TO AUTHORITIES
PROMISED AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE NEXT TRANCHE OF DOLLARS GOES
TO THE AREAS THAT ARE HARDEST
HIT PARTICULARLY IN MINORITY
COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY AMONG
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE ARE LEARNING FROM CDC
GUIDELINES THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
HIT HARDER BY THIS , SO WE WANT
TO DO IT RIGHT, BUT WE WANT TO
GET THE MONEY APPROPRIATED OUT
NOW.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, WELL THE
FIGURES UP TO ABOUT
125 BILLION RIGHT NOW, SO THEY
HAVE CONTEMPLATED DEMAND IS SUCH
, CONGRESSMAN MAYBE BY THE
END OF THE WEEK AFTER NEXT
ALL THAT MONEY WILL BE GONE.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE HOT TO TROT
TO GET THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY OUT
THERE BECAUSE THE DEMAND IS
OVERWHELMING.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER HOLDING IT UP
FOR ANY OF THESE OTHER REQUESTS
THAT YOU’RE MAKING?
>> NO AGAIN IT’S JUST TO MAKE
SURE IT’S GOING TO THE RIGHT
PLACES THAT WILL NOT, IT’S NOT
GIVE-AWAYS TO BIG BUSINESSES,
WHO DON’T NEED IT BUT LOOK, I
TALKED TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
EVERY SINGLE DAY, EVERY SINGLE
HOUR, ACTUALLY IN MY DISTRICT.
I KNOW THAT THEY ARE APPLYING
AND HEARING FROM THE BANKS THAT
THE LOANS ARE ON HOLD AND THE
MONEY IS NOT COMING THROUGH,
OR  AT LEAST NOT AS MUCH OF IT
THAT THEY NEED.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS MUCH
AS OUR SMALL BUSINESSES NEED, TO
PAY THEIR EMPLOYEE, COMES
THROUGH AND I ALSO AGAIN WANT US
TO BE ABLE TO REOPEN MAIN STREET
AS SOON AS IT’S FEASIBLE.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, CONGRESSMAN,
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME,